Новини дня «heute» з Барбарою Гальвеґ.
Добрий вечір. Вітаємо цього святкового дня
в нашому огляді новин. Про спорт
згодом розповість Норберт Леманн.
Сьогодні ми розглянемо такі теми:
масштабний наступ росіян на Сході України,
водночас канцлер
Шольц запевняє світову спільноту в тому,
що Путін не має перемогти у війні.
Спомин, сповнений горя й гніву:
стрілянина в початковій школі в штаті Техас
розпалила в США дискусію
щодо внесення радикальних змін у закони про зброю.
Нагорода за мужність:
три борчині за громадянські права з Білорусі
здобули премію імені Карла Великого
у боротьбі за свободу
та проти пригноблення.
Уже понад три місяці Україна чинить опір
російським загарбникам, демонструючи
надзвичайну готовність боротися.
Проте, ймовірно, українській армії
не вистачає ресурсів, щоб протистояти
великому наступу росіян на Сході країни.
Ситуація на Донбасі продовжує загострюватися.
Деталі - у сюжеті Лютена Лайнгоса
й Крістіана Фолька.
Великим містам на Сході України
загрожує путінська окупація.
Міста-сусіди Сєвєродонецьк і Лисичанськ,
загальне населення яких становить 200 тис.,
перебувають під постійними обстрілами.
«Подекуди ворог сильно переважає, -
зауважує президент України.
Нам потрібен час і допомога партнерів,
зокрема зброєю, повна допомога
без винятків та обмежень.
Достатня, щоб перемогти».
Сєвєродонецьку й Лисичанську фактично
загрожує оточення,
адже трохи південніше, в Попасній,
російській армії вже вдалося прорватися,
і така ж доля спіткає Лиман, розташований північніше.
Світлодарськ уже перебуває під контролем росіян.
Окупанти вивісили
російський прапор на будівлі міської ради,
а бойовики самопроголошеної «ДНР»
зайняли пости.
Українська сторона підтверджує втрату
містечка, за які точилися жорстокі бої.
Ймовірно, Луганська й Донецька області
повністю потраплять під окупацію.
Буде важко їх відвоювати,
але це лише два регіони.
Ще є Маріуполь і так званий сухопутний коридор,
де українські військові, можливо,
спробують з осені піти
у контрнаступ і повернути землі.
У Лисичанську українська поліція
виконує роботу поховальників.
Похорони неможливі через невпинні
російські бомбардування.
Упродовж останніх днів вони були вимушені
тимчасово поховати
понад 150 жертв війни в братській могилі.
Пізніше їх планують гідно перепоховати.
Йоганнес Гано зараз з нами
в прямому ефірі з Одеси,
міста, яке розташовано
приблизно за 100 км від фронту.
Які думки зараз викликають війна і дії росіян?
Особливо жорстокі бої точаться на Донбасі.
Але війна триває на багатьох фронтах,
проти мирного населення
застосовуються методи терору.
Вдалося витіснити російські війська з Харкова,
люди знову ходять вулицями,
вони вийшли зі своїх сховищ
і хотіли повернутися до нормального життя.
А сьогодні росіяни знову обстріляли центр міста
з артилерії, загинуло 7 людей, 17 було поранено.
Це чистий терор, спроби нагнати страх і жах.
Це ж відбувається і в Миколаєві, з якого можна
потрапити до Одеси. Місто щодня обстрілюють
касетними боєприпасами, і це не має жодного
стратегічного значення, це просто терор.
Росіяни стягують війська на Півдні,
тож припускають,
що вони планують вторгнення.
Поки що вони не можуть це здійснити,
але командир бригади нам повідомив,
що є велика ймовірність вторгнення,
і зараз терміново необхідне важке озброєння.
Його постачають задовго, місто потрібно утримати,
інакше Одеса потрапить до рук окупантів.
З нами на зв'язку з Одеси
був Йоганнес Гано, щиро дякую.
Федеральний канцлер переконаний, як і раніше:
Росія в цій війні не має перемогти
і не переможе.
Президент Путін
вже провалив усі свої стратегічні цілі.
Про це Шольц сьогодні заявив
на Всесвітньому економічному форумі в Давосі.
Там побувала й наша кореспондентка
Сюзанна Біденкопф.
Канцлер прибув останнім.
Його промова в Давосі була завершальною.
Ставлення Німеччини до війни
завжди було однією з тем на форумі.
Але цього разу обговорюють
і вже знайоме питання -
постачання зброї Україні.
Німеччина вперше
постачає зброю в таку кризову зону,
зокрема важку техніку.
Ми погодили надання цієї підтримки
з нашими партнерами й союзниками,
і ми поділяємо думку,
що наші дії ніяк не втягують НАТО у війну.
Шольц переконливо висловився
на тему міжнародної вільної торгівлі
і посилення міжнародної співпраці.
Він вважає, що сьогодні немає місця
протекціонізму й ізоляції.
Хочу наголосити,
що деглобалізація - це глухий кут,
вона не принесе результатів.
Багато представників бізнесу
відчули полегшення,
зокрема й головний виконавчий директор
компанії «VW»:
Світ, у якому країни діляться на блоки, -
точно гірший світ.
Це б загальмувало розвиток.
Менший поділ праці
призвів би до уповільнення прогресу
та процвітання у світі,
натомість - збільшення голоду й нових конфліктів.
Цьогоріч форумові задала тон саме війна.
Подекуди відчувалась безпорадність.
У Західному світі настав час
переломного моменту.
Його ніхто не чекав, він дещо хаотичний.
Питання як ніколи актуальні.
Зараз перед світовою елітою постає завдання:
разом відреагувати на нові виклики.
Від цього щонайменше залежить
її майбутній авторитет.
Форум у Давосі закінчився, еліта поїхала.
Тепер потрібно перетворити слова на дії.
У Штутґарті приблизно 30 тис. вірян
впродовж останніх кількох днів
чекали на З'їзд католиків.
Але й тут, звісно, не оминули тему війни:
як церква ставиться до неї?
Чи достатньо вона втручається в конфлікт?
Як щодо постачання зброї
й принципу ненасильства?
Зі Штутґарта сюжет підготувала Петра Отто.
Анна евакуювалася
з українського Чернігова до Штутґарта
машиною разом з онуком.
Він уже давно втратив мати.
Тепер загинув і батько.
На війні.
Багато людей з його бригади вбили.
У нього було поранення, несумісне з життям.
Мій син загинув.
Це одна з багатьох особистих трагедій.
Тож постає запитання,
яке обговорюють у день З'їзду католиків.
Віряни різняться думками.
Як можна допомогти?
Який внесок можна зробити,
щоб ця війна закінчилася?
Чи потрібно надавати зброю?
У цьому питанні я маю чітку позицію:
Україну необхідно підтримувати.
З іншого боку, зрозуміло,
що будь-яка зброя може когось убити.
Дилема.
Багато хто сподівається
знайти відповіді на З'їзді католиків.
Церква завжди підтримує мир,
і ми працюємо заради миру в усьому світі,
але, чесно кажучи, я відчуваю певну зневіру,
адже було так мало сказано й зроблено.
Цю думку поділяють представники
католицького руху за мир
«Pax Christi».
Вони стверджують, що церква робить замало.
Церква, єпископи теж повинні
заявляти голосніше
про свою позицію, говорити про те,
як можна досягнути миру в Україні.
Мир в Україні.
Вона вірить в нього і
хоче повернутися до свого чоловіка.
Він залишився вдома і допомагає
відбудовувати зруйноване місто Чернігів.
19 дітей загинули внаслідок
стрілянини в початковій школі в штаті Техас.
Наразі про зловмисника відомо
більше деталей.
Є підстави вважати, що 18-річний хлопець
розповідав про план стрілянини напередодні,
зокрема, у повідомленні
молодій дівчині з Франкфурта.
Окрім горя, люди відчувають
дедалі більше гніву щодо того,
що в США досі так легко дістати зброю.
Сюжет Ельмара Тевессена.
Напис «досить» на табличці -
адже вони вже бачили достатньо.
Конгрес має нарешті внести зміни
в закони про зброю,
щоб діти більше не вмирали
від гвинтівок у руках
організаторів масових убивств.
Присутні депутати та сім'ї жертв
стрілянини в школі Сенді-Гук 2012 року.
Час діяти настав ще 10 років тому,
коли в початковій школі розстріляли мою маму.
На губернатора штату Техас Ґреґа Ебботта
теж чинять тиск, адже він
з республіканцями
лібералізував закони про зброю.
Порушником спокою на пресконференції
був Бето О'Рурк -
суперник від Демократичної
партії на осінніх виборах губернатора.
У його бік лунають образи, адже він порушує траур.
Це якесь божевілля.
Губернатор розповідає про психічне здоров'я,
але ми дозволяємо 18-річному
юнаку купити гвинтівку.
Що ж ми думали, він буде робити?
Це наша провина!
Тим часом з’являються нові
подробиці про зловмисника.
На відео з камери спостереження
його видно біля входу в школу.
Відомо, що він розповів про свої наміри
у текстовому повідомленні дівчині
з Німеччини майже за десять хвилин.
15-річна дівчина прочитала
повідомлення значно пізніше,
тож не було жодних шансів йому завадити.
Сім’ї з міста Ювальді очікують,
що політики тепер нарешті
внесуть жорсткі обмеження до законів про зброю.
У певні моменти, як-от на поминках,
усіх їх єднає горе.
Однак люди знають, що у п'ятницю
губернатор Ебботт виступатиме
на щорічних зборах Національної стрілецької
асоціації, яка підтримує вільний доступ до зброї.
Повернімося до Німеччини:
міністерка закордонних справ Анналена Бербок
назвала їх «найсміливішими жінками в Європі».
Три борчині за громадянські права з Білорусі
сьогодні здобули
Міжнародну премію Карла Великого:
Вероніка Цепкало,
Світлана Тихановська та Марія Колесникова
два роки тому очолювали протести проти
авторитарної влади Лукашенка.
І дорого за це поплатилися.
Двом з них довелося емігрувати.
Марія Колесникова ж утримується у в'язниці.
Про день в Аахені розповість Єна Квон.
Їх вважають одними з найважливіших
постатей демократичного руху
в Білорусі.
За спротив самодержавному правителю Лукашенку
у залі Аахенської ратуші трьом активісткам вручили
премію імені Карла Великого.
Світлана Тихановська
вважає, що ця нагорода
об’єднує
всіх білоруських борців за свободу.
У єдності - наша сила.
Лукашенко та інші диктатори
хочуть розділити суспільство.
Наша єдність дозволяє нам
триматися разом,
тиснути на
режим, підтримуючи одне одного.
Вероніка Цепкало і Світлана
Тихановська живуть в еміграції.
Третя лауреатка, Марія Колесникова,
перебуває у в'язниці в Мінську.
На премії імені Карла Великого
в Аахені її представляла сестра.
Я знаю, що моїй сестрі
нелегко у в'язниці.
Минуло уже майже 20
місяців з моменту її ув'язнення.
Але вона не опускає рук.
Міністерка закордонних справ, Анналена
Бербок, у своїй промові
відзначає мужність жінок.
Вашу
сміливість не можна не відзначити.
Ідею свободи
не можливо викоренити.
Білоруські активістки - приклад
для багатьох людей, які сьогодні в Аахені
хочуть виступити за мир у Європі.
Тест складено.
Космічний корабель компанії
«Boeing» повернувся на Землю.
Після своєї подорожі
до Міжнародної космічної станції,
безпілотна космічна капсула
приземлилася в пустелі Нью-Мексико.
Раніше під час посадки виникали
численні проблеми.
Але успішний тестовий політ дає надію,
що незабаром космічний корабель
«Starliner»
зможе висадити космонавтів на МКС.
А зараз - спортивні новини:
Чемпіонат світу з хокею
у Фінляндії, Норберте,
німецька команда вилетіла у чвертьфіналі.
Так, трохи розчаровує, адже команда мала найкращий
у своїй історії результат у
відбірковому турі на ЧС.
П'ять перемог у семи іграх
принесли команді друге місце.
Сьогодні проти шестиразового
чемпіону світу Чехії -
поразка з рахунком 1:4.
Гра тривала всього дві хвилини,
перш ніж чехи в червоній формі
вийшли в лідери, дякуючи Пастрняку.
На груповому етапі вони показують,
беззаперечно, найкращу гру і збільшують
відрив завдяки Червенці до 2:0.
У другій третині матчу, на 32-ій хвилині, шайбу закидає
Крейчі: рахунок стає 3:0.
Відзначимо гол престижу Моріца Зайдера,
забитий після трьох невдалих
спроб та попадань у штангу, але, на
жаль, запізно.
Без німецького воротаря
чеській команді вдається забити шайбу
і завдяки Смейкалу вийти у півфінал з рахунком 4:1.
Водночас Німеччина уже протягом 69 років
чекає на свою медаль з Чемпіонату світу.
Німецька збірна з футболу не зважає на
вихідний День батька,
команда перебуває в Марбельї,
у тренувальному таборі,
та готується до турніру Ліги націй.
Настрій у гравців чудовий.
«Активно працюй і почувайся чудово», -
тренер збірної озвучує девіз,
яким можна влучно
підсумувати атмосферу у
тренувальному таборі.
Гансі Флік зібрав 26 гравців
під південним іспанським сонцем.
У кінці року він зі своєю командою
хоче дійти до фіналу Чемпіонату світу.
Між сезонними та національними іграми є проміжний етап.
І нам пощастило провести ці чотири дні тут,
за що я і вдячний.
Ми вже використовуємо
час для того,
щоб натренувати технічну тактику на полі,
а також  відчути,
що участь у Лізі націй для нас дуже важлива.
Не варто забувати про розваги,
а якщо гра з кулями іноді заважка -
сподіваємося,
що гра з суперниками,
Англією та Італією, такою не буде.
Гра з італійською збірною, «Лазуровою командою»,
стане першою у Лізі націй
уже наступного тижня у суботу.
А тепер короткий прогноз погоди.
На вихідних буде
вітряно, місцями штормитиме.
На Півночі можливі грози, на Сході - зливи.
Утім температура коливатиметься
від 16 до 23°.
О 21:45 запрошуємо до перегляду
«heute journal» з Марієттою Сломкою.
Бажаємо всім, а особливо татусям,
гарного Дня батька.
Дякую за ваш інтерес
і зустрінемось завтра.
До побачення.